He guardado esto en lo más profundo de mi corazón
durante años.
Pienso en ello cada mañana,
pero no hablo de ello.
Bueno, ya sabes, Robin,
que no debería estar hoy aquí,
debería haber muerto. 17/06/1940
el día 21 recibí 1 llamada telefónica
diciéndome que estábamos siendo
ocupados por el ejército,
algo que creíamos imposible.
Fue 1 Gran shock.
¿Qué opinas sobre lo que ha ocurrido aquí en Praga?
Esperamos volver a tener libertad y democracia.
Tenía 11 años cuando empezó la guerra
y 12 cuando llegaron.
Los soldados.
Estaban por todas partes.
Bajé las escaleras con mi bol de fruta y salí al jardín.
A mi Madre la mataron tumbada sobre mí para protegerme.
Imagínate, cuando tienes 12 años,
ver a tu Madre morir para protegerte.
Nunca lo olvidas.
En Timmy soara
tirotearon a jóvenes
frente a la catedral.
A mi padre lo enviaron a auswich
y allí lo mataron.
Mi Madre me entregó
sabiendo que quizá no volvería a verme.
No tenía tíos ni tías.
Era todo muy extraño.
Tampoco tenía abuelos.
Todo el Mundo tenía abuelos.
Yo no tenía a nadie.
E non si deve Mai dare per scontato.
Nunca Hai che Dar porcentata alla democrazia. Sempre,
sempre, appoyarla
e proteggerla.
17 de noviembre, cuando todo empezó,
hubo 1 Gran manifestación estudiantil.
Los agentes de la policía atacaron a los manifestantes.
Les dieron 1 paliza.
Fue entonces cuando comenzó la revolución.
Tras obtener la independencia,
Letonia se convirtió en 1 país libre.
La gente era libre de Expresar sus ideas
democráticamente
cuando cayó el muro de Berlín
comenzó la emancipación de toda Europa.
Querida Susan,
querida sus,
me alegro de que seas como eres.
Te quiero por ello.
Sabes que nací en 1 año
en el que el Mundo estaba en llamas.
Algo así tiene 1 Gran impacto en tu vida.
Afortunadamente naciste en 1 época de Paz y prosperidad.
Recuerda siempre que la libertad y la democracia
no siempre existieron aquí
y que podemos perderlas muy rápido.
Hay que luchar por ello,
siempre hay que estar alerta y luchar por ello.
Si pudiera, dejar 1 mensaje antes de irme,
vivid la democracia,
escuchaos unos a otros,
cuidad la democracia
cuando yo ya no esté aquí,
depende de mí,
depende de nosotros y de nuestra generación en Europa